tonight the Nevada Department of Health  and Human Services reporting 63  fatalities in Nevada linked to the  superbug it is known as candida Oris  also referred to as sea aorus it's a  fungus found mainly in hospitalized  patients now it can spread through one's  bloodstream and cause severe infections  in 2019 it was deemed one of five urgent  superbugs being monitored by the CDC now  they're called superbugs because it is  harder to kill with existing drugs cors  has been detected in over 25 Southern  Nevada hospitals if you're visiting a  hospital doctors recommend that you take  precautions wash your hands extensively  before and after your visit more  information on this fungus on  eightnewsnow.com